[Music]
you know there's a lot of people out
there that think the big news stories
today are the crisis in Egypt or how
best to implement Obamacare but judging
by local news coverage there's an even
bigger story that's sweeping the nation
a child's happiness is priceless
especially on a birthday but I honest is
priceless especially on a birthday a
child's happiness is priceless
especially on the birthday a child's
happiness is priceless especially on a
birthday well child's happiness is
priceless right especially you got a
birthday the child's happiness is
priceless especially on the birthday
child's happiness is priceless
especially on a birthday a child's
happiness it's priceless especially on
their birthday a chance happiness is
priceless especially on a birthday but a
child's happiness is priceless
especially when it comes to their
birthday
solutely tells happiness is priceless
especially on a birthday a child's
happiness is priceless especially on a
birthday well the child's happiness is
priceless especially on a birthday a
child's smile is priceless especially on
a birthday a child's happiness is
priceless especially on a birthday you
know a child's happiness is priceless
especially on a birthday the child's
happiness is priceless especially on a
birthday job's happiness is priceless
the child's happiness is priceless
especially on the birthday a child's
happiness is priceless especially on a
birthday a child's happiness is
priceless especially on
birthday you like that
[Applause]
you know who I wanna meet I want to meet
Lexy scheen Lexy that's my favorite
that's my favorite name Lexy scheen